So wollen Ländmann die Bewegung um die Längsaxe, sieht dann gerade so aus, entstehen natürlich auch beim
berufenflug, aber auch Einflug in die Thermik seitlich kann der Schirm aus seiner Achse gebracht
werden und die bei den Längsaxe anfangen zu rollen und das geht es natürlich dann zu verhindern,
das heißt wir wollen ein Schirm wieder wie wir uns stabilisieren. Damit man sich das Ganze mal vorstellen kann,
habe ich diese Skizze hier schnell angefertigt, also wir haben uns am Startpunkt und wir ziehen uns
eine gedachte Linie und um diese Linie du mehr eigentlich den Schirm jedes Mal, wenn wir in den
Träumen gebracht haben, so weit mit der Bremse wieder ausrichten,, sondern dass er wieder zurück
auf diese gedachte Linie fliegt hinkommen. Aber eswas wäre so, dass die Zick und Zick
und diese Linie zu fliegen, also wäre das toll. Jetzt wichtig beim Rollen des Körpereinsatzs
Bremse und es kommt immer zuerst der Körper und später die Bremse. Probiert die Bremse auch nicht
zu schnell zu ziehen, sondern so eine gewisse Dynamik in der Bremse drin zu haben. Also durch wie ich
Bremse warten, beim Bremse ziehen noch mal ein bisschen bis zur Brust und dann freige ich.
So ein gewisse Dynamik gewicht auf die neue Seite warten, bei Bremse ziehen noch ein bisschen mehr bis zur
Brust und wieder freige ich. Das wäre so ein dynamischer Bremsausschlag. Jetzt wann kommt der
Wechsel, das ist immer so die Frage, wo viele geloten und Schüler stehen. Wir beginnen mit dem
Rollen nach links. Das heißt, wir richten den Schirm nach links nach dem Aus der Pilotbendel
rechts außen hin und jetzt wenn der Pilot am höchsten Punkt ist, dann kommt bereits der Wechsel auf
die neue Seite. Das heißt auf die rechte Seite, das Gewicht lehnen, sodass wir möglichst noch nicht
mit der rechten Bremse arbeiten müssen. Der Schirm aber schon ein bisschen auf die neue Seite aus
wird, nach dem untersten Totpunkt die Bremse ziehen. Ich ziehe es noch mal schnell vor, das heißt
Gewicht reinhängen, dann Bremse ziehen bis zur Brust, dynamisch ziehen, zack hoch und
gericht auf die neue Seite. Und jetzt warten bis wir unten vorbeigebendeln sind, gerade um
mit der Bada nach Bremse ziehen, etwas dynamisch zur Brust und wieder bräuchsen. Zack, warten,
warten, warten, warten, bremse ziehen, dynamisch ziehen und zack, warten, warten, warten, warten,
warten, bremse ziehen, dynamisch ziehen und ausleitung, sehr einfach, wir mit dem Rest letzten Roller
gemacht haben, rechts, zack, Hand hoch, können wir in den Krallen sitzen bleiben, beide Hände
oben lassen, warten bis wir hochgepennt sind und jetzt kommt der Schirm wieder von hinten nach vorne,
beide Hände bremse aus den ganzen Herbos, einfach warten bis wir drunter gependet sind und dann
langsam treten. Eigentlich so vor der Erklärung her sehr sehr einfach, aber es braucht ein gutes
Zeitmanagement, Bank und der Körper, wie extrem kann man den Körper dann auch schnell rüberlegen und
wann kommt die Bremse nicht. Auch da fangt am Anfang lieber langsam an, wir steigen uns mit jedem
Mal im Meer, ich sage mal, drunter sind ein bisschen mehr oder noch ein bisschen kräftiger, oft zieht
man die Bremse dann auch ein bisschen kurz oder die eine Seite mehr als die andere. Also da
ist wirklich wichtiger am Anfang, beide Seiten gleichmäßig, beide Seiten zur gleichen Zeit und die
Intensität von der Bremse muss auch auf beiden Seiten, die gleichmäßig aussehen. Wenn wir jetzt,
beispielsweise bis zu hoch sind, wir machen hier die Wolle auf die linke Seite etwas zu hoch,
dann kann es sein und klappt der Außentflügel ein. Wenn das passiert, nicht mehr weitermachen,
unbedingt aufhören, warten bis die Schirm ausgependet ist, entweder mit beiden Bremsen gerade
stoppen oder die normale Ausleitung warten bis die Schirm von hinten nach vorne kommt und dann
mit beiden Bremsen abfangen. Da sind wir lasse ich euch aber sicher nicht weitermachen. Gut. Für
das Rollmanöver wird eine vorgegebene Fluggaxe aingenommen. Durch dosiertes abwechselndes
ziehen und lösen der linken und rechten Steuerleine, erfüllt ein rütmische Schaukeln um die
Längsaxe. Vorsicht, zu starkes Anbremsen oder falsche Intervalle können zu gefährlichen Flugzuständen
führen. Ab einem regelmässigen Rollen genügend kleinere Steuerimpulse um die Schwingungen bis zum
richtigen Winkel aufrecht zu erhalten. Um das Manöver auszuleiten, wird ein einzelner
Puls ausgelassen und dann das letzte Rollende Schirms mittels Bremsimpulse und nachfolgend
dosiertem freigaben der Steuerleinen abgefangen.